regardez cette image presque des péniors
Emmanuel Macron en Hitler qui provoque
forcément la stupéfaction à la place de
la moustache trois chiffres pour 49,3 le
tout souligné d'un non merci très
explicite pour l'instant qu'une plainte
n'a été déposée mais les autorités
locales ont ordonnée l'effacement de la
fraise
c'est ce qu'on vit actuellement il dit
que moi je trouve que la fresque qui est
quand même choquante parce que comparé
quand même Macron un président démocrate
qui était élu par le peuple
une dictateur c'est quand même gros
quand même
heureusement
oui c'est un graffeur qui avait déjà
caricaturé Jacques Attali comme ça avec
des relent antisémites d'ailleurs il
sera jugé bientôt et là moi je trouve
que c'est purement scandaleux alors
heureusement le préfet a décidé de faire
enlever cette fraise tout de suite mais
je ne comprends même pas on est le votre
avis qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
immédiatement pour moi alors voilà c'est
inaccept combien de temps là l'arme ne
tolère pas ça elle est encore là
elle est en train d'être
du plex
elle est en train d'être enlevée
elle va être enlevée oui le préfet a
pris la décision a été prise je croyais
que vous parlez à la Régie apparemment
[Applaudissements]
et prise de l'enlever non mais tout est
dit dans la petite phrase en dessous de
la la peinture il dit ceci est une œuvre
satirique donc voilà c'est une oeuvre
satirique alors la comparaison est
Hitler elle est certes violente elle est
disparue
alors pourquoi la Une de Charlie Hebdo
avec Macron décapité ça passe et on dit
rien il y a pas de sens
mais voilà donc moi là au moins même si
c'est violent même si c'est
disproportionné le message je pense
qu'il y a c'est pas le côté
une caricature
hitlerature c'est ça le message en
revanche quand je vois Emmanuel Macron
décapité en Une de Charlie Hebdo je
trouve ça gratos je ne comprends pas je
trouve ça violent et là personne ne
parle de sanction
exactement moi je suis pas choquée par
Charlie Hebdo parce que pour moi c'est
un journal satirique et là pour moi
c'est une insulte à l'histoire c'est à
dire que malgré tout au caricaturer
Macron en Hitler il faut quand même le
dire le marteler je sais pas si les gens
oublient parce que quand on arrête pas
de dire qu'on vit en dictature que c'est
un régime totalitaire il faut quand même
ne pas oublier que que Hitler a tué 6
millions de Juifs exterminer un
programme qui s'appelle la Shoah de de
d'extermination de race de d'handicapés
de tzigane de gens qui émotionnels
d'homosexuel et je pense que on oublie
aujourd'hui ça et on a trop vite fait
aujourd'hui par des raccourcis de dire
qu'on vient en dictature et c'est
insupportable en fait et oui moi je
trouve que effectivement cette
caricature et ce dessin est une insulte
à l'histoire et c'est juste immonde
voilà Castaldi ah bah moi franchement
les mots les mots ont un sens Adolf
Hitler et on peut le comparer à personne
voilà tu as tout dit et dans ce cas
précis c'est un président de la
République il a été élu une dictature on
est on prend le pouvoir lui il a fait
que des horreurs il a pas tué Simon et 9
millions de personnes il a pris il a
fait une guerre qui a fait 50 donc de
morts c'est impossible de comparer un
homme politique un démocrate à cette
personne et on peut pas même pas
représenter la personne sur sur quelque
chose c'est impossible moi je suis
bouleversé choqué vraiment si vous nous
joignez est-ce que cette stress que vous
a choqué d'Emmanuel Macron c'est à
Avignon donnez-nous votre avis on est
bien sûr en direct il est 19h35 Daniel
non ce qui est grave c'est justement
mais alors moi c'est c'est ça c'est très
très choquant et ce qui est grave c'est
qu'en fait vous avez vu le un des deux
jeunes gens dit bah c'est très bien
parce que on sait exactement ça on vient
parce que tout le monde qu'on vous a
demandé
c'est juste que je sais choqué et il
faut qu'il ait une sanction énorme parce
que vraiment c'est c'est je vous dis ça
les gens qui ne connaissent pas bien
l'histoire ça brève cette idée qu'on est
en dictature c'est complètement faux
donc évidemment je vais dans le sens de
tous mes camarades c'est parfaitement
choquant c'est inadmissible on peut pas
comparer Guillaume il est pas choqué
et ben tu as tort parce que c'est très
choquant d'utiliser le visage ou la
mémoire d'Hitler qui est une horreur
qu'il ne faut pas oublier d'ailleurs
parce que justement on l'a évoqué les
meurtres qu'il a commis là on n'est pas
en dictature je suis désolé moi pour moi
la petite musique c'est
surtout il y a une forme de relativisme
parce que c'est Hitler c'est le perso
qui est dérangeant moi je veux alors
après la préfecture à demain tu prends
un rouleau de peinture blanche tu repars
c'est fini c'est on en parle plus c'est
réglé moi c'est les limites ça j'en veux
pas et Charline Charlie Hebdo me fait
pas rire quand il le décapite et ça ça
me fait pas rire non plus voilà c'est
toujours pareil c'est là tu es tu es un
peu comme moi toi moi voilà même te
faire rire comme ça m'a pas fait rire ça
ça me fait pas rire mais la dame qui
avait mis en place
de ton président
tu as fini le Macron tu dis en fait
c'est kif-kif Macron Hitler c'est la
même chose tu vois bien que c'est quand
même une faute pour moi ça fait des
années qu'on nous bassine ça en France
quand même
il y a plein de gens qui ont dit qu'on
vivait en dictature en France depuis des
années notamment avec la crise du covid
ça ne craquer personne là je pense
sincèrement je pense mais ils ont pas
été condamnés
encore une fois il ne fait pas référence
à l'antisémitisme ou à la choix je pense
qu'il fait référence à la nature
a beaucoup fait réagir les chroniqueurs
notamment et vous et vous chez vous
également on est juste à voir c'est pas
l'auteur doit-il être sévèrement
condamné oui alors si vous voulez mais
c'était est-ce que ça vous a choqué
cette phrase qu'on va voir ce que vous
dites non pas être condamné à 71 %. donc
71 % des gens sont d'accord avec euh il
y a un truc en France qui s'appelle le
droit à la satyre donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi
ne faites pas dire n'importe quoi aux
gens il y a des gens qui ont vu ce truc
là qui ont compris en France on en
dictature on peut être d'accord avec ça
on peut être pas d'accord je pense qu'il
n'y a pas de référence là-dedans même si
il y a une référence à éclaire
évidemment sur au niveau de la moustache
il y a marqué 49-3 il y a aucun rapport
entre le 49,3 et l'antisémitisme le 49-3
il dit juste que et le fait de faire
passer les choses en force c'est
assimiler une dictature Hitler était un
dictateur aussi et c'est ça la référence
aussi
de toutes les horreurs je suis là mais
comment est-ce que tu peux mettre un
signe égal entre
les deux on a le comme Charlie hebdos
ils ont le droit de de guillotiner
Emmanuel Macron lui il a le droit de
faire ça et arrêtez avec vos amalgames
dégueulasse
tous les gens qui vont comprendre ce
dessin sont antisémite encore une fois
vous créez des raccourcis qui sont
dangereux je pense que le mec il a fait
ça n'est pas anticipé
vous créez un truc ou des des des des
dès qu'on est pas d'accord avec vous on
est antisémite on est homophobe etc…
c'est l'émetteur qui peint qui écrit qui
dessine quand c'est Charlie Hebdo on
sait qui écrit qui ce sont des
journalistes qui qui ont le droit de la
satire etc là en l'occurrence c'est un
monsieur qui est déjà sous les feux de
la justice parce que parce que soupçonné
d'antisémitisme parce qu'il a déjà fait
une fresque où il dépend Macron comme
une marionnette de d'un autre de Jacques
Attali qui est donc le grand capital le
Juif qui de qui tiendrait le monde donc
qui écrit qui dessine à chaque fois
l'émetteur est important c'est sûr que
quand tu as ces infos là ça exactement
à la discrimination à la haine par
propos à caractère antisémite là alors
déjà c'est purement et simplement
antisémite
et c'est lui qui manipule donc c'est
honteux voilà et je suis désolé moi
Guillaume pour moi ce n'est pas de la
liberté d'expression ce n'est pas merci
merci on arrête on va voir le sondage
s'il vous plaît on doit passer à autre
chose oui et voilà êtes-vous choqué non
à 81%